Scoops it to Mard lot of ice out there no one-time
available kale itching M back to kale the one
timer Nathan M Kennon the game-winning overtime
power play goal for his 20th of the season and
the ABS have come back to defeat the New York
Islanders plays it around the boards McTavish
is first on it across the top of the Zone Fowler
winds and fires and a good screen from vrono and
Jones has it wow Riley set up C Arro for
a overtime game winner earlier this year
here's Riley with the puck gets it to Marner and
a good spot Matthew stores it's a game winner and
number 30 for Austin Matthews and the leaps win
backto back in Southern California watch just a
little delay by Marner here that make it look
like you're going to shoot and then as soon as
Matthews kicked out he's able to release it and
the go tender unable to get there quick enough
how about that zier trying to give the Flyers
the lead in the shootout a good move teris off
is there with a glove Johnny goodro moving in on
Arison and scores it's quick hands little change
of pace then it's oh pull him one way and then
go back the other on the forehand he zigs and
zags his way in very deliberately and could not
be there I think he gets a pat on it JJ you're
right zig zag and then now that left pad gets it
florer who's 1 for three 33% he's got a score to
keep them alive and the Jackets win danil terasa
turns aside all three Philadelphia shots shushin
will turn on to his forehand slide it for McKinnon
trying to take on Harley spin move played well got
a back hand away save rebound and Wedgewood got
the left leg down on the in tight rebound feel
it out of the Zone instead they turn against the
grain it's McKinnon it's mukin mukin got rid of
the checking up another overtime hatti winner
here's Sean he could do it charging in tried to
spin it to Robertson nice poke by Robertson got it
to Sean could not stuff it wide of the net R hints
a switch of directions usane sent it back to him
now duaine he's in a backand save gorv tried to
go wide and he's cut off by Taves in a brilliant
defensive play banged ahead and McKinnon's got
to break away to win it in overtime he scores
Nathan M Kennon wi it an overtime and and the
comeback is complete Sav by gorv Point Blank a
little poke check in there that fouled up Matt
duchaine the former RAV and a great defensive play
by Devon Taves initially one-on-one with Robertson
ready make changes wman El lead pass and here's
a break to win it to break it put it over the net
part of that was the change issue for the Kings
here is Spence again looking for a play dubba to
the bench Spence feeds it in front spinning Kee
Kings the other way feet ahead to fiala to chase
down fiala to the net a shot save is made by lion
into the Zone fiala a cross ice pass to soft look
out two on0 to break it a breakway in Deeks
save is made we play on an overtime a battle
but the Red Wings Kan in away with it Kane into
the Zone back is more Kane a shot save rck six
seconds left long lead pass broken up cider down
to the circle shot at the buzzer save made we go
to a shootout wow what an overtime Trevor Moore
will start the shootout we went five minutes in
overtime without a whistle he likes High glove we
know that more in gaks save is made round one for
Detroit comes in on an angle picks up speed
and scores now Raymond had all those chances
in overtime Adrien Kee two of three this year
two goals in regulation in shoot save is made I
think lion got a Blocker on Patrick Kane on RIT
it's over Showtime's done it again and the Red
Wings win it for to three R it gets a piece of it
watch this but there it is there's the brakes now
it's stick andle stick andle stick andle stick
is there initially pass the jump out quick and
go after the puck to the corner Miller right on
him C Field's got it shoots quick the save wants
to play it and can't get it away fast enough
h a shooting M the save trying to throw it in
front Coffield Coffield waiting back M shoots
pick the save now the Rangers with a Chance
foxo doesn't f hard jumps on it and Aaron's got
it he'll stop waits for help feeds it across
laier in the slot can't get a shot for tro BS
a tro drops it off for FOX NOW gets it in tight
back headed towards the net by tro it's over
the goal behind the net had it taken away by
gson fired up on the boards and saan has got it
left for near going to the m foran come out for
the CH it turned back the other way
Saban with a great job of picking
that off the wall and he feathers this
over the lap here and you're not going
to get a better look than that what
a beautiful save by monteo lack for
in nearfield for M back looks in the
clock he knows he has to hurry man B
shoots stopped by MBO wow they're on their
feet at Montreal what a night for Samuel
mimo P one for one or one for two on the
season comes in panan hand goes wide Nick
Suzuki Cuts wide now gets back to the slot
Waits fs and can't get by qu far he fakes it
like he's going to tries to open up Monto
Mo five he makes the first save and then
a really really Beauty on the second one 6 for
14 in his career hfield Cuts wide down left as
well saan at 0 for two on the
season 41% in his career saan
oh gets the paddle down and knocks it away
weed do another here mik aanad tries the
forsberg to wait out Mont Ball but he's
got the paddle of his stick waiting on the
goal and for good reason look like a wide
open net unbelievable save by two for three
on the season yes with a chance to win it
put it off the post three for seven in his
career w for there in AO and the Canadians
win it 4 to three terasa with a kick save
goodro comes up with it goodro Springs Fant
Tilly fantelli back to Gad to fanelli a
shot and he missed the Target high and
wide Joe Hansson centers ban couldn't get
a shot away Eric S at the side of the net
and now it's a three onone Johansson trying to
catch up with the play bean sends it across to
a glove save by flurry what a sensational
stop shikov can only shake his head he's
the man you want to get this Puck he gets
it look at the open net whoa whoa that is
incredible wild have numbers now coming out of
their Zone Rossy to Baldi Baldi Works
through the middle goes to Rossy he's
gone the rookie wins it for the Wild and
Mark Andre flurry has win number five 51 43
Minnesota Rossy puts it in the spot where tasov
gave up a goal to Johansson just a few minutes
ago That Elbow area under the glove now St Louis
trying to mount the attack coming back the other
way set out in front one chance two chance oh r
on side it maybe a little help from his friends
the I think it was the blocker hand without the
stick what a say gets his glove the way he turned
it over it ain't my blocker it's a glove oh he
actually couldn't tell until now he gets it as
Jarvis is going to go for a change and drop it all
the way back back for ronto 215 left here overtime
Here Comes fetch the C he's got speed goes in
on Bon and he'll make the save just can't tell
sad trying to finish it fresh legs special C was
really Shannon Ley on the ice for St Louis now
burns with it burns makes a move com up from the
back hand and Bennington held the line Burns tries
to end it takes it to the house see if the canes
can force a little pressure Here Comes forward and
it'll be Shen Shen Will Roll in rotto he's bumped
off of his Mark but he makes the save and now the
canes have numbers because Shin's all the way back
it's three on two AO trying to get it across oh WS
shoots that's deflected witon he's four of six
as Burns comes in on bton forand and Bennington
makes the save now it's Pavo bunich 0 for one this
year on the shootout coming in on waiting waiting
waiting and R excellent movement in his crease
at the top of it AO one for two in the shootout
this year he's coming in Bennington challenge
a back here W he scores oh beautiful move oh
amen Bennington tries to surprise him with a PO
check he misses by a country mile and AO uses his
reach AO amen let's see if Ron can put this to
B that's Jake neighbors bearing in on Ron first
ever career shootout Neighbors in and he scores
well here comes Jordan martinook for Carolina
he's charging in on bton with speed backhanded
just missed and the Blue's Captain storms into
the Zone Shen waiting waiting and he scores Shan
wins it the captain ends it in the twoot out and
the Blues win two to one they'll seek Refuge back
behind the cage here comes the breakout c l flying
down the wing K to the B Zone in front through
it threw it off the leg of Swingman the left P
was out there right there he's got to grab a try
andle upstairs he just couldn't find the Rhythm
to make the right rer going to be looking for it
that time the one timer not available now cross
eyes quick shot there sorgio and here's a shot I
was wondering what that hit cuz it made a weird
sound T just killing some time the puck is loose
to maoy bster do shoots nice job there by goria
and Tes just killing time in that corner now he's
got to get to the bench he's got no gas left here
goes the change Here Comes Coy and he drops it off
to brush one timer bust off sa by gorg works it in
with speed with the corner Circle walks in and a
good P check by goria that'ss it at Center ice and
he working down the left wing here's thein it in
looking to the forand thein it shoots at a save by
S gloves his way across the Blue Line looks down
the slot M and shoots at a save by S he'll pick
it up at Center Ice poock slow down the slot
po set here one of the silkiest mths in the
National Hockey League he spored in a sh like
this just two weeks ago and he went top shelf
on that same from P to not very often just kind
of came in casual try to disguise the quck Here
Comes Val works it in the chin slow toward the
front of the N hold Sho SC B toin the shootout
goal and the ABS beat the Boston brets by a final
score of four to three stos off the right side
Steven stanos in shoots Sav by Calvin out the
king Stepping Over The Line Spence over skated
that one dug out by heel hegel's going to take
off here it comes Brandon Hegel cut back hangs
on works it into the corner he's bear hu there
by Duo there go great work get it a perect per
he's in an overtime winner from Nick perit and
then look at him just a foot race with Spence
but he stops and keeps it under control and keeps
spinning around and keeps it under some kind of
control when he's being two onone that allows
fix to make a move away kuss is out there with
Cur fooot and DBA and this one will be played
look out poock the other way poock is in and
he's stopped by Conor Ingram Oh man and Matt
Dumba with a pat on the head for Conor Ingram
and then when the players come out it'll be four
on for holding and holding here's a chance Keller
is in he's robbed omark preparation on makoy and
a power move on the backend melli out High coie
thinking about a [__] with a look over the top
oh that didn't miss by much perfect tries to play
it out of the Zone it goes here's another
opportunity poock is in poer knock off the
pipe he'll bring it in schaltz
is Off the Bench Nick schaltz
right to the front he scores Nick schz OT
winner Nick scholz how you doing first shot
on swayman he goes and in picks up the puck
and ow and tippet looks like he has his mindset
on exploding all the way down the ice and he's
checked it back and the shot by L the chest I
save all the way back across tale's out on the
ice he's got the puck rise de with the pass he's
got frost in a go save Primo good passes just good
some great plays all throughout this game got
L stick was being held he still still gets to
the puck though got it up fr the shot oh this
save up high firers have it back one more push
there's connect with lton Cony moving up to lton
the shot oh the save by Primo spectacular and now
the other way it's Anderson Jos Anderson rumbling
on in save Aron he catches up to him and then he
gets the opportunity to turn this into a mini 2on
one what a save by kayen Primo coming across and
then it's Josh Anderson the other way 8 seconds
remaining tippet tippet racing up ice 5 Seconds
tippet cutting in TI with the back header
the net comes off the puck stays out steady
with his choices in the shootout swing in from
the left wing this time exst Suzuki who's over
50% for his career 11 for 21 four for seven this
year deliberately on in and harison just waited
him out he's seven for 15 in his career three
for seven this year way to the left wing and
on in save there Bobby rink ends it with a goal
swings way to the right wing and he goes to the
back hand and the save by Primo had him down
he did Elevate this Puck but just a good job
by Primo getting that blocker over there as well
oh man just a little bit ESS and who's three for
five in his career in shootout attempts two
for four this year has to score Cuts in daks
and he's stopped by Arison three for three Aron
guys all the attempts the Flyers win the hockey
game corv that's out there for the
face off one back to doson doson for
B it's
over who had the icing trying to connect with
maew it sets up this yeah you know and you look
at that icing call too they were trying to set
it up Circle back find Hughes who moves in on
Carlson Quinn Hughes protect the puck FES it back
Miller kicks it up he shoots J the sa Here Comes
Pon around Malin drops it for Myers wrist shot
save made by jar he'll play it to Malin he'll
back it Forward Russ with a burst to speed here
comes Brian Russ wide in the net quickly as they
were crossing the blue line here comes Jake
kensler he's got to step on Miller gets him
back hand save made by dco they move it Pucket
Center broken up and here's Herona to Pon trying
to win it in overtime Alias Pon pees scers he
snuck it through the legs of jurry as Pon was
able to get away from Crosby brilliant play two
goals and two assists for patteron two goals for
besser three assists for Miller and the Canucks
withstand that late time goal the speed you want
in Len right there Larin trying to get away from
dry cdle who stayed with him Larin though able
to get right in the goal and just sent it high
loose for Raymond knocked Away by picker minute
10 into the overtime McDavid will change as
well a hand off to Zack kyman hard in the net
rolls in front turned over there shs and scores
this game is over Darnell nurse wins it 3 2 in
overtime tie a club record
with a ninth straight victory
see Lion's got no stick in comes heer and now
Brad takes it away and it's a two-on-one back
the other way flipped into the middle and
trying to get it with his Hughes he does
shoots and it's a stop by baseski what's he
going to do CRA to radish radish back to krov
going to cut in CRA with the backand pulls it
back still with it gets it to radish his shot
St Darren radish with a light ni strike in
overtime BS win it and that's all kerov needs
somebody get open I'll find you and then radish
takes good aim and he's got a rifle of a shot
playing it ahead deah breaks in oh mour nearly
had the steal but then bosski makes the glove
save deis breaks in he's he's got a chance off
the post and we continue Panthers dodg the bullet
barov carries in over the line barov will give it
back the flip here's kachu in front off the post
the other way I don't believe it kachuck had talit
beat Reinhard over the Blue Line gives toar off 5
seconds left in overtime here's Reinhardt on the
doorstep for the back scores let's go home baby
Sam Reinhardt extends the winning streak to nine
peanut butter jelly time trust the backand and
he just roots that thing top cheese now stone
cutting through Center Ice into the Zone with
petrangelo stone looking to petrangelo he scores
Alex petrangelo second of the season from Mark
stone and a great pass to Alex Patron to leave
him at tap and rale turns it over it's Eric s the
other way ryale chasing ericon X can't get a shot
off fers to the puck and they Roar back the other
way there is concy not there a long time he'll
flip it on the right side comes across to zamu
back across tippet tippet takes it back from far
the power play about to end zamula holds waights
fire score far in front with a redirection
and the Flyers win the hockey game 4 to
three and as you mentioned a power
play goal now in four straight and
another game where they battle back
from being down what a gutsy win of
Crosby watching pesy tavana didn't
like what he saw so he'll turn it
away Crosby wants a change ter tries to take
advantage he'll drop his back P she shot he
scores two for 22 tonight Burns fought for
possession and once you get possession be patient
with it and that's exactly what Terra vinan was
Suzuki gets to the Edmonton line left it for
Coffield drops it off for mat mat around the N can
will stop in and he got stopped for Conor McDavid
off to drle dyle back for McDavid again McDavid
moving in with it hands it up Bard Firs Evan
musard the overtime winner and it's a franchise
record for the Edmonton Oilers 10 straight
victories the B bomb Evan Bard just teas this one
up but you can see just a little bit of a screen
by his own guy ghy also a little Movement by
himman stolen by Kyo makoy takes over two on one
scores Charlie maoy inic fashion now kmo
will pick it up along the left wing wall
kmo trying to walk to the net BCE off a check
saved by Ms leans Pon tried to fire the bis it
but failed and now a penalty Patterson as
he attempted to haul down singer who walks
in kick save and then how about this that puck
just goes off the across the line Johnny good
r soering a passinger in front off the glove
of the Smith and bounced just wide of that far
post shoot out this season comes down that left
wing Moves In Good Ro denied the pad save of the
Smith Delay from kusco stopped by m lein what he
got up his sleeve down the right wing slows it
right down and a pad save by just Smith pson makes
his second attempt here in a shootout this season
he hears from the crowd and there's Elvis to make
the save we're going overtime in the shootout four
everybody's on there Maro down the left wing the
right handed shot there's Maro and he scores just
poke that puck ahead and that little sha beats
and surprises the Smith Elvis needs a save and
the jackets will come from behind for a victory
oh this time that find the file hole and it's
smooth out Alexander texier and there marchenko
Elvis needs a save here moves in does sooner Den
I jack wi Elvis M leans return turns to the net
and in Jubilation picks up the Victory and Fowler
says let's press the issue two onone he's got
vrono with him cam in a hurry trying to open up a
passing Lane the trailer color walks in backhander
fought off by stolar Ducks get it back color again
he scores Alex color an overtime game winner
there's the stop by stolar again but watch where
this shot goes by Alex color right through the
legs and underneath the glove a stolar 6 seconds
to go hofman steps on it hofman now hurdle save
moric rebound swatted to the corner right as the
overtime horn sounds of the goal tender moric who
is brilliant all night long you can see it's a bit
of a knuckle puck right there and kinsky with the
quick hand slides that one away and here's shooter
one and kers puts it off the iron he beats
Blackwood over the Glover pass the glove
quickly but off now Kevin leank the New York
native leank in the middle scores boy he came in
with authority right there RM pitlick his fourth
game as a Blackhawk in the shootout on Blackwood
pitlick scores Oh What A Move looked like he
was going to lose control of it but that move
toas hurdle moric challenges hurdle slows and the
Poke check by morazzi a number of good chances and
he tries to go back to the back and look at now
Lucas Reichel reichal stopped by Blackwood to the
fifth round of the shootout Jason Dickinson off
the post no it comes to a rest on the goal line
continuation of the shot he almost kicked
it in to morazi's left now cunan stopped
big save morzin that is a kick save
run to the middle run another stick
save by morazzi Johny bow 15th shootout
shot Zack Sanford he misses off the post
he beat Blackwood and couldn't finish oh my
goodness he did everything right looks like
he beats Blackwood here pulls it to the
backand and then gets it up and around
him Alexander barabanov for the win save moric
now Boris kachuk he steps on it kachuk backand
score it's Philip Zaden Zaden SA bazic Hawks
win couple of former Wings right there and
moric has the answer Keller back through Center
K's got it kolie is in kie shot it over the top
he's still got it Logan kolie goes to get it
Logan kolie and another shot that's deflected
off Zer went for the five hole last time and
this time he tries to go over the glove still
picks it up takes it he goes okay I'll take
it again but how about the stick right now
Anderson again over to L he switch spots LOL
rer stopped by a rebound sto that two s off
the goal line Conor rram right there and he
saves the goal and cry gets to the puck first
around the board Sher goich able to keep it
in 20 seconds left he takes a look shoots
scores even the goal tender Ingram knew
he didn't even protest didn't piran cross
Markin plays the caram Mika tries to get chew
it pan puts it in front pun check by moski and
then pan is blocked away able to protect the
puck as he does so well goes back to go topar
again up high with it Lin he SC Red Wings win
it they're third in the Atlantic 32 comeback
victory they've done it again 60 and one their
past seven games gos fair over to Lin he waits
waits for a shooting Lan Jones in front of
the benches gains The Zone Jones a shot he
scores it's set Jones's first goal of the season
and it's an overtime game winner just trying to
get himself in position and a great wrist shot
in the perfect spot Conor skates it into the
Ottawa Zone turns from there Lowry trying to
cut to the net poked Away by coroso the Chuck
is the only change for the senator so you got two
tired guys on the ice Norris jumps off now eers
brings the puck in though here's eers a shot
they looking back and reaching back is corol
the Puck's still loose now W's got a chance the
other way sta has Sanderson trying to catch up
Jake Sanderson a shot H about the save alexai
have follow Waits and he gets it right back
in front and a follow did Coro get the Blocker
on that t knock it Tim St as SMI will play it
back he played it over and that one was close
to being too many men now here's a steal from
berson he's got numbers Shabbat back for berson
off his gate look there breakway back there the
way KY Conor trying to get back in Shabbat Conor
stop by coroso it looked like he was headed off
and now peels back here's a guy that can scoop
to n eers breaking in on TI to the back hand
scores felt like it was going to be a guy
with speed and skill and that's exactly
what eers is and how about this individual
effort and that beautiful backand this is
carried in by Matt duchane and Matt barzel
made a nice defensive play to take it from
him and now barzel starts ahead banked it on
for Bo Horvat with a path to the net Horvat
L Islanders take Patrick W debut in overtime
32 over the Dallas Stars checks to Shane down
low and just keeps his feet moving Dallas gets
caught up the ice and what a good move this is
as he gets outside pulls it to his back end Jer
brat has nine shots on goal already today and
he carries to the offensive end he accelerates
it and he rips it it didn't go but they can't
get that ever Stevenson surging the other way
could be a two-on one Stevenson all the way
to the net vanich makes the save I'm he's sure
big save there by vanich ecoes changed off Teo
Myers come on Jer brat streaks him again he
shoots again he hits the crossbar time they
did have the pocket ended up being a partial
break management makes the save there's a Holtz
gains The Zone cuts to the front he Fe for br
he shoot got it go down Holtz was buckled what
a shift for Holtz L Hughes intercepts three on
two L feed shot Tyler toing a half trip and a
win Vegas has control again but they turn it
over in the neutral zone and what a pass and
patience there by Luke Hughes Thompson is down
and to fo he buries it now the kings in with
Byfield a shot save has made rebound loose fiaa
into win it shoots save is made Co now recovered
by the kings in fiala watch this one two you
really didn't budge he didn't Flinch fia the
other way hurdle two onone hurdle in hurdle
shoots save is made toas hurdle robbed by rid
here's Couture in against David rid and he
scores Logan cure comes through Kee is two
of four this season Kee moving in shoots save is
made he scores the Sharks win in on an angle in
on goal shoots and scores and the Sharks two
of two in the shootout eckan able to get it
to tr but he lost it and cider with it again
goes cross ice and Blackwood with a save off
Miller slow the puck down to stop the puck
I should say stur slows it and sand for the
shark coch feran and fox for New York and
the sharks have it and they're two on one
if they hurry zerland with Couture and
he shot it wide Ruda gives it back for
Alex baranov keeps it in the zone here's
barano he'll bring it around the ranger
n hurdle heads to the front of
the goal barabana Ruda hurdle go
hurdle he just takes that extra second
to make sure a couple of really nice
plays off the bucket did not again the
Jets doing this without Josh Mory since
late in the first period here's the shot
well sto him another confident save by
samsonov here's cter it's going to be four on
four momentarily what a move and Sams it off
with the stop there off deers as Nick eers
just showing great patience got the D going
down in McCade the block could reel that pass in
Lowry spins out Robertson gets it again here's
Robertson trying to twist away from peon now
he goes the Benet Thro scores Austin Matthews e
winter it's number 39 for number 34 11 career
overtime goal for Austin Matthews try to get fresh
legs up there b hes for the Ben for Vancouver
replaced by Alias Pon here's Paro moving in
it's a two-on-one down lowo shoots kicked out by
the Smith and the C set numers the other way JT
Miller he's got Heron the net there's the pass BL
save by hord he gives the pck away to Miller back
toon leas Pon over skated him as he tried to make
some moves on he runs out of real estate great job
by Shannon now leny with the blues into the Zone
leny waiting and looks in front but everybody's
covered but he's still with it for Shan wide open
and he scores Shan the winner in overtime what
a win by the blows in Vancouver and de brus will
build speed from the back charge into the Zone de
brusk centers brri denied by po solo drops that
back for Mar finds his way in drops it off for
Coyle Charlie Coyle set the T purpell makes the
save in comes T again Marsh the in shoot rebound
oh CH for K Chucky on that cors back the other way
with marad Sanderson back defending Mara in shoots
SC gra Mar over TI winner and Boston takes it
fre to and man it's a two-on-one situation coil's
going to get it over to Maran right away Oran head
up the whole way and he just picks his spot switch
of directions and then a handoff for Terry who's
got a goal in the game shot and hinger makes the
save only face 20 they've got pavelski hints
and Harley and pavelski wins the defensive Zone
draw so first possession of overtime for Dallas
here's Harley charging ahead Thomas Harley he
scores the overtime winner for Thomas Harley
Joe pelski who's been terrific tonight wins
the draw and then Thomas Harley RPM redlines
it all the way down the rightwing side tting
its way away from pressure down low to Malin up
the wall with it if Genny Malin lost possession
with the head for mour stole it back by Malin
he sends it Rael rard Rael holding it spinning
Malin does he have another in him Crosby charges
in holding it blocked and monor's got a breakway
penguins are trying to get back Brandon Moor
all alone poke Jack M Del the hot poker out
of nowhere lost the puck it's 5 seconds in
overtime Bennett lost it Carlson a chance
Marin back stick save bski at the end of a shift
tried to cut in and there's the Poke check first
shooter Rael against babski using the whole ice
and babski never move never bid on any of those
fakes trying to give the Panthers the lead against
NAD delovic and the save is made and here he comes
Crosby to give the pens the lead in the shootout
save Bovi Alexander barov trying to give bosski a
chance for the win barov stick handles and it's
in off the post and in for barov the Panthers
Road winning streak is a franchise record seven
Jake gensel moves in and he scores up the glove
unbelievable boski thought he had it in the
club look at he's looking at his Club about
the only thing he doesn't have this year is a
game the Sid Ang goal here he comes Reinhardt
for the win let's go home baby Sam Reinhardt
all through this adversity all game long and
they're able to they gain the Zone neighbors wide
forced wide by Schulz Thomas right in stopped by
dord he'll move it along for Justin Schulz that
broke the Stick of Andre steel it's Thomas delay
out in front it eludes The Stick of neighbors
gourd was all over him Seattle back out out
Schulz takes a peak Here Comes Tatar he's in a
shot kicked out by Bennington who's trying to
complete a line change catching the Kraken Tire
B David comes in po check rebound oh Shen hit
the side of the goal after B Davis drove the
net and now B davit in front to Shan B davit
he scores a winner by B davic and the blows in
overtime I've done it again to get the victory
but pav bvic up high then Bron Shen little
hot sauce There nice little sauce pass and
then pavich oetkin a nice move pass to Shane Alex
oetkin in dropped it on the right side the Stars
collect Duane ahead gets it back flipped it
on the left side Robertson over to Harley he
shoots he scores he's done it again eser he's a
Springer he's a fat boy driveway Subaru of Moon
Township overtime slapovi one-onone with bang
around of Jar he gets the best of them big stop
to keep the Penguins in this game Chris crosses
with Anderson throws it to the net bounces right
to Raquel pens out a two onone it's the sweds
Raquel and pson here comes Marcus Pon fir he
STS
gracious does he wire this thing is that a
no look homom fell down and the Panthers had
a peel back here comes Brock Nelson Sav by stolar
he moves it ahead Evin Rodriguez with emman LaRon
going to the net two on one emman LaRon let's
go home Baby Oh e l in O and Rodriguez carried
that Coast to Coast with butter toast and Oliver
emman Larson tucks it underneath that crossbar
hon couldn't come up it here comes Columbus
three Blue Jackets to Center shikov in on the
left wing puts one in the middle Johnny G dishes
offal to save on a one timer from Zack liny good
communication here Johnny checks his shoulder
to see where Zach is and he freezes everybody
and then puts it on a t for Zach rinsky and
he's able to recover get the P to STS around
gar now sends one ahead chinik moving in with
a shot kicked out by D with the right P Brock
besser turns with the PT B passes to Miller
we're halfway through overtime JT Miller on
the move he shoots in the glove saved by m
leens who flashed out the left hand watched
by Fant Tilly Comer changing besser's back out
takes the pass steps around Johnson Brock besser
across
as they Rally from three down and beat
the Blue Jackets 54 and overtime n BS in
this game night skates away from copar
here he comes Thomas to the front and
a save by R what a move there by Robert
Thomas and he waits locked down in front
by B davic Shen behind the defense gets
it here he comes Shan CH he scores Shan
again the pick it up here is the puck
comes up the wall and Bron Shen just
comes in on the left wing M takes the P
advancing we got a two on0 here G over
to J Yoshi and no shot back the other
way another two onone here's the action
we been waiting for jaru get a back SC
back to jaru one timer and cl jaru scor
then he joins the rush on the way back great
oxygen tanks by CH he's at the front of the
net with Tero now gradually moving up over to
shabat crossing the Blue Line Pinto to the net
with ti to and he scores Shan P but what a
beautiful setup by Thomas Shabbat I mean and
and he had to reach forward Pinto Conan and the
shark still possess as Jacob McDonald goes to
the front of the net he gets the pass across one
timer off the mask of Gibson and that brings a
whistle time and blowing the Whistle the Sharks
weren't threatening to get to a rebound of any
kind the big Russian snaps it ahead trying
to jump around here's duclair Swept Away by
lome who reached back Terry picks it up under a
minute to go ATT two-on one with Ponto to prick
scor he's going to the allstar
game a fans going home with his
stick and now it's a two-on one young
defenseman Muk Mulan back Terry waits
for the perfect time as saucers
that pass over to for Toronto and